This morning we'll take up one of the themes that is to say we've described how
the courses about specific diseases,
but it's also about a number of overarching themes and one of those is the
development of various public health strategies.
So far as you remember,
we've dealt with three public health strategies.
One was the system of plague measures,
sanitary cordons,
lots,
directos quarantine and all the rest of it.
We've dealt with vaccination as a public health strategy with regard to smallpox
in particular,
and we've talked about a third policy if we want to dignify it in that way.
And this was the strategy of concealment.
This morning I want to talk about a fourth approach to public health and this
was what's called commonly the sanitary movement.
This was pioneered in Britain in the 1830s and forties and it was then exported
to the continent in North America,
assuming particular forms in France,
in Italy with the actual rebuilding of cities in accord with sanitary
principles.
Now the sanitary movement was the first to define itself as a public health
movement and it had two essential meanings for its term.
The first was the prevention of infectious epidemic diseases.
And the second was the removal of filth.
So it's based in a sense on the relationship of filth and disease.
Indeed,
many people talk about the filth theory of disease as lying at the basis of the
sanitary movement.
It's focused therefore was on the towns and cities that had sprung up with
urbanization and the industrial revolution
epidemic diseases disproportionately claim their victims in the cities.
And correspondingly,
the legacy of lasting effects was priests specially pronounced in urban areas.
And the sanitary movement is one of those lasting legacies.
Now there is a theory that uh,
we may as well look out just for a second developed by the British physician and
demographer Thomas mccown and it's often called his thesis where he was dealing
with the demographic fact of what he called a mortality revolution,
a demographic transition in which cities for the first time become places that
are dependent for their expansion,
not only on inward migration to the towns,
but on the fact that the longevity and the birth rate come to exceed the death
rate,
which was something new,
a real demographic revolution.
And why was this achieved and many people have thought and postulated that it
was due to medical science to conscious policy
and those sorts of explanations.
Mccowen instead stresses to factors.
He sees this as largely unplanned and do to improve nutrition,
but also and not the point this morning to the role of sanitation.
In other words,
the population explosion,
the demographic revolution is something that he postulates,
which due to,
not to medical science but rather to the sanitary movement and also to nutrition
well,
what was the background to the sanitary movement?
We've seen and mentioned that there really was a tremendous challenge to health
in this period of the industrial revolution in European history.
There were tremendous changes afoot in British society.
There was the rise of a modern commercial agriculture and with it and closure,
the driving of peasants off the land.
We know about the major demographic growth that was underway by this period
supported by the new agriculture and the fading of the threat of famine and the
fading of the threat of plague.
There was the rise of manufacturer and then the factory system,
especially the textile industry and the associated an unregulated horrors of
things such as long hours,
low wages,
child labor,
you know,
to that across Europe,
urban populations doubled in the first half of the 19th century and in so doing
overwhelmed the infrastructure of available jobs,
the housing stock,
sanitary arrangements and all the rest so that we see the rise of tenement slums
sweatshops.
There was a mass movement of population from countryside to town and with
thought went psychological adjustments.
There was a breakdown of older notions of social relations based on paternalism,
of the customary notion of a moral economy based on moral obligation.
And we see in said the rise of the principles of impersonal relations of a free
market economy unless say fair epitomized in the new discipline of political
economy with such figures,
of course as Adam Smith,
Ricardo,
Jeremy Bentham,
Thomas Malthus.
The result along with those transformations was a rise of new social tensions.
We've talked about the 19th century as the rebellious century.
Now in Britain,
there were no social and political revolutions,
nothing comparable to 1789 in France or to what happened on the continent in
1830 and in 1848 and nine but contemporaries weren't certain at all that this
was going to be a lasting fortune for Britain.
And indeed Britain did have a number of signs of severe social tension as well.
There were large scale riots.
One could mention the chartist movement and in the country side,
the movement known as Captain Swing,
so urban and industrial centers.
Also in Britain,
we're perceived as dangerous politically for fear of the so called dangerous
classes who rioted perhaps committed crime,
threatened revolution,
and we're dangerous medically as well.
That is,
they were infected with cholera and other diseases and it was cholera in
particular.
That was a real prod to action,
this new and most feared disease of the 19th century.
It's not by chance then that the sanitary movement begins in the 1830s and
forties and Britain after that is to say the first pandemic and the second of
Asiatic Cholera
and it lasts intermittently down through the first world war.
And this really was a vast movement.
It was nothing less than the retrofitting of the urban centers of the nation
with the specific goal of removing filth,
because filth was held to be the cause of disease.
So we're talking about one of the great public works projects of modern history,
the establishment of sewer systems,
a whole infrastructure of water mains of waste removal,
street cleansing improved unless crowded housing,
the creation of parks and public spaces.
So we can see that Victorian Britain truly was preoccupied with that combination
of excrement and water.
All of this of course presupposed as well.
The emergence of a modern state.
It was state power.
That alone provided the wealth and organizational structures that were needed to
carry out this enormous project.
And in turn we can see the causal chain working in both ways because the
sanitary movement was and very important factor in reinforcing state power.
It's implementation meant that the state now invaded areas of life formerly
regarded as private and appropriated for itself enormous new powers.
And the reformers were supported by Protestant and especially evangelical
Christian churches.
Well,
who were the leaders of this movement?
And I think we should turn first of all to this men,
Sir Edwin Chadwick.
This is Edwin Sir Edwin in his younger days.
This may be a slightly more familiar picture of him.
Uh,
I guess maybe at my age.
And then he case,
I'm sure Edwin wrote a major work,
um,
collaboratively he produced it,
let us say a that which was called the report on the sanitary condition of the
laboring population of Great Britain of 1842.
Now,
Chadwick wasn't a physician at all and this is part of the background perhaps to
the thesis I was mentioning earlier.
He wasn't stead a lawyer by training from Manchester and he was already well
known in particular for his reform of welfare provisions in Britain.
Uh,
that is,
he was responsible in large part from the passage from the old poor law,
which had provided relief as the birthright of every citizen in distress.
That is the right to some form of assistance or aid in time of distress.
Chadwick's idea was to economize,
to minimize the cost of payments,
to discourage the poor from applying for relief.
He wanted to make the experience of receiving relief more painful than the
experience of distress itself.
A principal that was dubbed the principle of least eligibility,
the workhouse and other words was to be a place of punishment,
of pain and of suffering.
So work should be in the workhouse more unpleasant than any to be found in the
labor market.
And the Diet should be intentionally made to be loathsome
more so than what could be found by the poor outside.
So the poor law bureaucracy was also invoked and was an essential foundation of
the information on which Chadwick relied for the sanitary report of the laboring
population of Great Britain.
And this was the man who was the same in both faces with the new poor law and
with the sanitary report.
The sanitary reform was also a stark assertion of state power as a means of
social control.
The intention was to discipline and civilize the working classes in the interest
of social stability.
Following in the wake of the report was the establishment of a public health act
of 1848 and Britain and a general board of health and such champions of sanitary
reform as John Simon,
Thomas Southwood Smith and you know our nut.
Now let's talk for a minute about this men's ideology and his intentions.
The this was a class based movement.
It was top down and centralizing in chadwicks mind.
The poor were largely responsible for their own plight.
They weren't innocent and they certainly weren't harmless.
His mission was to cleanse and civilize the dangerous classes.
As I said,
he wasn't a physician and his reforms were not based on any new medical
discoveries on scientific experimentation or observation to determine what
measures were most effective by determining the causes of disease.
Is reform measures enormous as they were were based more on what was the common
sense of the period and a priori assumptions.
Public health this way
was separate from the development of medical science.
His view,
and this was widely accepted,
was that medicine was about private persons,
not so much public policy and his idea was to use public policy to cleanse the
urban environment but not to deal with other social and economic determinants of
disease.
We'll talk about that in a moment.
We need to think not only about what Chadwick wanted to do,
but we also need to think about what he decided not to do,
what wasn't important to him and so we should see this as progress.
Yes,
but progress that came at a cost and we want to know about that as well.
Now an influence on Chadwick's thinking was the essay on population of Thomas
Malthus who believed that there was a law that in every society population
pressure sooner or later pressed against the limits of subsistence.
So real improvement for the poor was likely to be illusionary sort term and
perhaps counter productive in the long run.
Really significant improvement couldn't occur according to Malthus.
It might even be self defeating,
leading to disease,
starvation and war.
Those great positive checks on population increase.
That idea of the limited nature of possible improvement was an chadwicks mind.
The poor will always be with us.
Okay.
There was also,
as I said,
the filth theory of disease.
Um,
we know it,
we've talked about my asthma and that's long history in European thought.
Well,
filth now was associated very closely with smell and if you are to read the
report at some point you would notice that smells constitute an important part
of the report.
The report is filled with descriptions of stench.
The authorities consulted by Chadwick,
frequently used phrases such as I was assailed by a most disagreeable smell.
And it was clear to me that the air was full of most injurious malaria by
malaria.
That's another word that occurs throughout the report.
And we should note that before malaria came to mean a specific disease,
it meant bad air from the Italian model and audio bad air.
And so this report in Britain in the 1840s is filled with descriptions of what
they called malaria.
Let me you an example from the town in the West country of Truro.
Uh,
the reporting to Chadwick,
the reporting official said passing into Saint Mary's parish.
Their proportion of sickness and deaths is as great as any part of truer,
but there is no mystery at all in the causation.
It'll constructed houses with decomposing refuse close upon their doors and
windows open drains bring the oozing of pig sties and filth to stagnate at the
field of the walls such you're a few of the sources of disease,
which even the breezes from the hills cannot dissipate everywhere.
The reports discovered disease and they correlated the disease with such
findings as poisonous vapor,
more [inaudible],
effluvia filth,
obnoxious of flew via poisonous exhalations,
my asthma and malaria.
The moral of the texts of those conditions also preoccupied those who took part
in the report,
vice alcohol in temperance,
and then more poverty and still worse more filth.
Poverty was partly the result of depravity and in providence and those in turn
reinforced more poverty and more filth.
Well,
there was a political aim behind the sanitary reform and I think we might call
this a transformation that Chad would,
was aiming at in the demographic composition of the British population.
In chadwicks mind trade unions,
which he a poured demonstrations,
strikes the chartist movement and all the rest were called by Chadwick wild and
dangerous assemblages,
but he noted that they were mainly led by the young,
older experienced workman with family responsibilities.
He found to be moderate and temperate as a and not to take part in strikes and
social unrest.
Therefore a high early death rate and poor sanitary conditions.
We're actually politically destabilizing,
at least in his mind,
because they led the early death of workman and hence to an overrepresentation
of the dangerous young and an underrepresentation of moderating older workman.
Well,
if we want to understand and explain this view,
perhaps we could invoke an anachronism to make an analogy and we could use the
analogy of a nuclear reactor and compare social unrest to a meltdown of the
reactor core with disastrous consequences will in terms of the reactor to
prevent such events.
Reactors make use,
as you know of Boron control rods that are inserted to control the rate of
fission of uranium and plutonium and to limit chain reactions.
We'll,
in this way.
What Chadwick wanted to do by analogy was to use older people like control rods
that would have the calming effect of Preventing Social Meltdown and social
revolution.
But to do that you had to do something about infectious diseases to achieve this
demographic transformation of the population.
So if infectious disease was destabilizing for the state and political order,
a population subject to infectious disease moreover is unlikely to be educated
and to be open to the moral influence of the clergy.
And the absence of cleansing and towns,
Chadwick felt would lead also to demoralization and further depravity.
Now and all of this thinking,
let's remember to at what was lost.
A striking feature of Chadwick's view was the narrowness of its focus,
the cause of ill health in Victorian Britain,
I think we should say not the cause.
The causes were undoubtedly multiple and one could think about low wages,
unregulated factories,
inadequate diet,
poor clothing,
lack of education,
working conditions in sweatshops,
mines and factories,
child labor,
overcrowded housing.
These I would call social and economic determinants of disease.
And there were voices,
particularly on the continent for an alternative public health that would
address precisely such broad interests.
There was an older tradition of what was called a medical police on the
continent and the current of thought of what was called social medicine,
whose most prominent figure,
uh,
was this men Rudolph Veer cough,
a physician who lived from 1821 to 1902 and was one of the great figures of 19th
century medicine,
a physician,
anthropologists,
biologist and radical politician.
No,
his view was that disease was not simply a biological event,
but as socially driven phenomenon.
And his meaning of the term social medicine was that physicians should treat not
just individual patients but entire societies and that they should pay great
attention to matters of the economy,
to diet,
wages,
housing,
child labor,
working conditions.
So veer cough was in a sense the Anti Chadwick Chadwick's intention instead was
to focus on the narrow issue of filth and water.
And his attention was confined.
The working classes and the filth in which they lived at stake was the issue of
how broad should have public health movement be.
And perhaps one could say that one of the sad features of the period was the
triumph of the,
now our was to gauge division of public health,
the solution in chadwicks hands.
And this was a major event in public health.
There's no doubt about it.
I'm trying to say,
not that this was unfortunate.
It was only unfortunately narrow Chadwick solution involves technological
measures.
All good in themselves,
drains,
sewers,
water pipes,
but they didn't include social,
economic and educational reform and the reforms all came from above and
reinforce a centralizing state rather than finding ways to empower ordinary
people to participate in defending their own health.
Let me give you an example of a tech simple technological improvement.
It might be hard to recognize when you first look at it,
but,
and I'm talking about some very humble movements that have enormous political
and medical consequences.
What we're looking at is a sewer main and these were established under the soil
of cities in this period.
And one of the technological inventions was to make the sewers egg shaped so
that you would maximize the flow and they would be self cleaning and um,
they would drain most efficiently.
So technological innovations of that sort or a part of it now the victory of
Chadwick's vision of public health wasn't simply automatic and so it was worth
to keep alternatives in mind.
His side was the winning side in a debate of the early 19th century and a wider
view like that of your cough was present but lost the debate.
No,
let's be clear.
In summation,
I'd argue that Chadwick's vision of public health was highly successful.
That it was a crucial part of the mortality revolution of 19th century Europe.
But at the same time something was lost or broad vision of the causes of disease
and those causes weren't addressed.
So although what Chadwick achieved was a major in positive advance,
it perhaps fell short of what might have been and it German straights,
the practical and positive impact of miasmatic theory and public health,
uh,
theory.
And this is perhaps something we want to bear in mind that a theory that is by
now rejected that is my asthma TISM.
The fill theory of disease did operate in such a way as to promote major and
positive health results and one of the causes of this movement was the epidemic
disease that we dealt with the last couple of times and that is Asiatic cholera.
We might note there was a side light that may be of interest as well that this
sanitary movement,
the literal sanitary movement was accompanied in some places by what we might
call a figurative sanitary movement and that is moral sanitation.
And one of those was particularly notable in France where there was a great fear
of another disease that we'll be talking about slightly later in the course and
that is syphilis.
Remember the early 19th century,
we're dealing with the period in the wake of the Napoleonic wars
and with those wars as always happens there or happen,
there was a major upsurge in socially transmitted diseases and in particular
syphilis.
And so this sounded,
Terry Movement was accompanied by the Movement for moral sanitation to the
registration and surveillance of prostitutes and in France,
those responsible for moral sanitation actually made the link explicit.
That is to say that they compared brothels with sewers and sad that they,
the brothels should become the target of sanitation.
So this was a form of moral sanitation that was an offshoot of the literal
sanitary movement that we've is our main theme
now,
the sanitary worldview led also on the continent to further off shoots and that
I want to talk now about continental form of the sanitary movement,
the rebuilding of cities in their entire team.
This was actually much more comprehensive and systematic.
It means urban planning.
It's more comprehensive than what happened in Britain,
which was the retrofitting of cities with sewers and drains and sanitary
provisions.
It entailed the actual leveling of whole cities or neighborhoods within them to
start a fresh in accordance with a comprehensive plan.
Now,
there were a number of prototypes and France,
Paris,
Leon and Marcee in Belgium,
Brussels in Naples,
that is in Italy.
There was Naples as you know,
but also Florence lists Betsy and other places.
But let's begin in Paris because that established the pattern
here again,
we see the influence of epidemic cholera,
which ravaged Paris in the 1830s and again in 1849 and this caused an enormous
psychological shock.
The idea that civilization was no sure fire protection against sudden and
agonizing disease,
there was an unbearable contradiction.
That is city,
that is Paris that prided itself at being at the heart of European intellectual
life,
at being the leading city and the arts and culture.
A world center,
as you now know of scientific medicine could nevertheless be devastated by a
disease that was associated with poverty,
with filth,
and with the colonial world.
Well,
after the revolutions of 1848 to nine,
we have a reactionary and authoritarian regime
established by Louis Napoleon Bonaparte or Napoleon.
The third,
um,
that soon became this second empire that lasted for me Tiene 51 till 1870.
Well,
there's Napoleon the third,
and I want,
he undertook a major movement to rebuild Paris.
And I want to argue that this had enormous sanitary consequences intentionally
so and that the epic experience of epidemic cholera was very important in the
establishment of that,
but I don't want to say that the rebuilding of Paris was solely designed as a
health measure and solely to prevent the return of cholera.
There were other games as well.
Napoleon the third wanted imperial splendor.
He wanted a city that would be worthy of the role of France and the world that
would be a showcase for his new political regime.
He too was thinking about social control,
so there was a political aim that was to destroy the working class slums that
had been the sights of rebellion.
The idea was to use urban renewal to remove workers from the center of the city
to distant suburbs and in the center to construct wide boulevards that could be,
could not be defended by barricades and that the troops could move quickly,
use to move quickly across the cities and cannon balls could fire down the
boulevards to demolish barricades.
In other words,
Paris was to be made revolution proof,
or at least that was the goal.
It was also a project of public works that is,
it was a means of enormous patronage.
It would provide employment and would diffuse social tensions as well.
So powers under Napoleon the third became a vast public works project.
Uh,
enormous shovel ready projects.
The workers of Paris then would be employed and therefore largely pacified.
It was thought that this would also have an economic role.
The new boulevards,
the wide spaces would facilitate the movement of goods and assist free trade and
commerce.
And then there was the public health objective to improve health to prevent the
return of infectious epidemics.
The task was entrusted to this men,
George Oh Smuin the prefect of the sin.
And often what was accomplished is referred to as the ost monetization of Paris
with the so called great works are good on travel that were undertaken from 1852
until 1870 now this project was authoritarian.
The rights of individuals were disregarded,
the population was not consulted about being moved and it was an operation of
colossal complexity.
All of the affairs of one of the greatest cities in France.
The great city in France were gathered into a single pair of hands,
finance,
administration,
transport,
sanitation,
engineering,
architecture,
evictions,
expropriation of land by eminent domain,
slum clearance,
gas fixtures,
and lighting,
sewers.
All of this was an enormous assertion then of state power.
The means were broad intersecting boulevards.
Let me show you the sorts of plans were to have the great boulevards of Paris
that you can see today
that such as the rue,
the Rivoli,
the boulevard distrust book,
Sebastopol,
the Boulevard,
San Michelle.
The average size width of a street in Paris was to be doubled and underneath the
streets there were to be sewers and drains the words to be water supply and
there were it to be broad parks and public spaces such as the broader Bologne.
The aesthetics were the aesthetics of the straight line.
We can see that there.
We can see it also here and you can see the intersection of these broad
boulevards and you can see how these were had mult.
We're multipurpose and would allow not only part of the idea was the miasmatic
one that they would allow air and light to sweep through the city and remove the
noxious smells and purify and cleanse the city.
And you can see as well that they would be good for commerce and for social
control.
So Paris after Osman was clearly much healthier as a city than before and call
Laura did not return there afterwards to the city center.
But there is an irony here that cholera did return less vehemently then before,
but in the 1890s,
it did return but not to the center of the city.
And in other words,
part of the sanitary problem of Paris was not entirely solved,
but was exported to the suburbs and it was the suburbs that experience the
return of cholera in 1892.
So we have to see this as an enormous sanitary success,
but one that we want to qualify.
Let me look at much.
Look,
this is a map,
a picture of the demolition to convince you of what a major undertaking this
once.
Um,
and there's the,
uh,
view of the new open spaces cleanse with light and air and germ free and also in
Napoleon,
the third mine.
It would be also,
um,
make revolution much more difficult.
Well,
there was the political sec success as well as the sanitary was a success,
but one that needs to be qualified.
There was an enormous resentment among the working people of Paris at Ost months
project.
And there was an enormous history from that time down to nearly our own of
hostility of the suburbs.
Paris becomes not by chance surrounded by a red belt of concluding hostility to
the regime.
And this exploded in the summer,
spring of 1871 in the Paris commune that brought down the regime and led to the
establishment of a republic.
So they're all so political qualifications.
Well,
I'll move then to another example very quickly and one that,
uh,
is in the reading and that is the Italian version.
And in particular the,
the Nissan,
the men tall of Naples,
which was Italy's largest city,
as you know,
there was a massive epidemic in the city.
This is,
oh,
this is the plan of the de Sana Minto in Naples.
And as you know,
it led to the idea and here is something that is actually unique that is to say
that we've talked about the retrofitting of British cities and also American
ones.
We've talked about the rebuilding of Paris.
Those were associated with a variety of disease experiences and they had
purposes other than a single disease.
One can't see through a retrofitting of British cities as due solely to epidemic
cholera nor the rebuilding of Paris.
Here in Naples,
we have something that's unusual and probably unique,
which is the actual rebuilding of a major European city for this specific
purpose of preventing the return of cholera.
And the way that the plan was developed reflected the specific medical
understanding of the time of the cause of cholera.
And we see here to a form of the fill theory of disease.
The rebuilding of cholera was for the single purpose.
And the medical theory behind the rebuilding project was the specifically the
miasmatic theory of this physician from um,
Bavaria.
Munich in particular who has mocks van Patten coffer,
who had an enormous influence on public health.
And one aspect of his influence was not his theory lay at the basis of the
rebuilding of Naples.
He developed the most sophisticated of Maya's Madec theories in the 19th
century.
And when his aim,
the aim then behind the rebuilding of Naples was to thin out the population.
Overcrowding was a cause of disease and poisonous vapors arising from underneath
the city poison the air,
people breathe in the poison and succumbed to cholera and mocks Fenton coffers
you.
So the purpose of the Sana mentor then was first of all to raise the level of
the streets.
That is to say the danger and the MIASMA was if we like fermenting beneath the
streets of the city.
So you want to place a greater distance between the population living above and
the poisonous Effluvia arising from below.
And so the aspiration was to raise the level of the streets to the second story
of the houses.
And there would be,
if you like,
then a massive cushion including the mortar of the streets themselves,
between the population of the city and the danger lurking in the groundwater
beneath the soil.
In addition,
the idea was that you would have Naples,
there's a picture of the old city that's uh,
in various aspects that's being demolished.
And here what I wanted to show was this,
the great access at the center would,
and then there were various cross streets.
The uh,
great boulevard at the center was in the direction of the prevailing wind and it
was called a bellows of fresh air that would allow the wind to rush through the
city,
drawing up the,
um,
uh,
flew via and blowing away the stenches and allowing the sunlight to reach ground
level.
And then that would be crossed by a series of wide boulevards as well.
And then under the,
if this happened above ground,
there would also be work going on beneath and you would have a whole sewage
mains being built,
uh,
under the city.
So we SANA mental,
this enormous project,
both above and below ground was related,
was a cousin of the sanitary movement in Britain.
It was a first cousin of the rebuilding of Paris and Leon.
But it was distinctive too because it's the only example of a project conducted
exclusively for the purpose of defeating a single disease.
And that was cholera.
Was it a success?
We'll,
Naples was rebuilt and there's no doubt that the health of the city thereafter
was greater than it had been before.
But unfortunately there too,
there was,
there were qualifications.
The rebuilding was marred,
marred perhaps partly by the flaws in its conception from the outset,
but marred also by the fact of corruption and the misuse of the funds that were
carried used to carry it out.
And so we see thereafter that although Naples was rebuilt in the aftermath of
1884 that there was a return of cholera,
a major epidemic again in 1911
and there was even a small Coda to that,
which is another outbreak even in 1973
so the irony in conclusion,
the sanitary movement in Britain,
retrofitting of cities.
Okay.
The rebuilding of cities and France,
the re Sana mental and Naples did achieve major success.
Okay.
But it's worth remembering that they often weren't based on a medical theory
that was to endure.
Okay.
And indeed in the case of Naples,
it was a medical theory that very soon after the rebuilding was to be discarded.
No sooner had Naples been rebuilt down.
The theories of Patton coffer,
uh,
were overturned with the coming of the germ theory of disease.
So when we're,
one of the questions we asked them was the lasting impact of epidemic diseases.
And I would argue that one of the senses of lasting impact is one that's
embodied in bricks and mortar and urban planning.
And if you visit,
uh,
the cities,
then you can see the lasting legacy of epidemic disease and the urban landscape
itself.